aquí vamos a hablar de una posible
solución al rescate hasta el momento
hemos discutido acerca de cómo comenzó
la crisis crediticia y por qué la actual
propuesta de rescate en primer lugar es
mala desde el punto de vista moral y
equitativo
en segundo lugar que probablemente no va
a funcionar aún cuando se implemente así
que pues porque si quiera considerarlo
algunos de ustedes me dirían bueno pues
cuál podría ser la solución en vídeos
anteriores hablamos de que realmente no
se puede legislar la realidad se tiene
que dejar que las cosas se corrijan por
sí mismas y no se puede crear riqueza
simplemente aprobando leyes pues
solamente se intercambia quién es el que
va a recibir las pérdidas y debido a
esta discusión recibí una carta
electrónica de un amigo mío de la
escuela de negocios es una persona
bastante inteligente y es una persona
que yo respeto mucho y él ha propuesto
una solución que yo considero es muy
buena y la sugerencia de mi amigo es que
en lugar de comprar bienes que no valen
nada porque no crear nuevos bancos que
sean totalmente capitalizados por el
gobierno aunque igual no sería necesario
capitalizar los quizá y dejar que estos
bancos hagan los préstamos directamente
a las personas oa las empresas que lo
necesiten y él tiene varios puntos
interesantes él dice que con 700 mil
millones
de equilibrio y por lo tanto más
posibilidad de dar préstamos que todos
estos bancos que están involucrados en
el rescate los cuales son los pilares
del sistema financiero en estados unidos
y ellos representan 690 mil millones de
equilibrio en libros y esto es lo que
ellos dicen que tienen como valor en
libros de sus bienes pero ya vimos que
muy probablemente han inflado esta cifra
ya que quieren que se compren estos
bienes en un valor mayor de lo que
realmente tienen que seguramente esos
bienes de estos bancos no valen nada y
él indica que el nuevo banco no tendría
préstamos previos comprometidos y la
cantidad de dinero que podrían prestar
se incrementaría lo que significa que no
se le daría un préstamo a un agujero
negro cuando se presta dinero se da
dinero a estos bancos que tienen malas
obligaciones el dinero sencillamente se
está vertiendo en un agujero negro ya
que no hay ninguna seguridad de que ese
banco nos pueda devolver ese dinero pero
si ese dinero se invierte a un banco que
tiene una hoja de balance prístina un
nuevo banco y de hecho yo recomendaría
que hubiera varios bancos para evitar el
problema de ser demasiado grande para
caer' y podrían hacer préstamos y
recibir préstamos de la manera más
prudente mi amigo comenta que esto
cumple el objetivo de inyectar capital
para préstamos en el sistema sin crear
un problema moral y al final de algunos
años el gobierno podrá recuperar lo que
invirtió en estos bancos por más de el
valor original generando un beneficio
sustancial a los contribuyentes y a mí
esto me parece una solución excelente
otra variante sería por ejemplo crear 10
bancos y que cada banco tenga un capital
de 70 mil millones y a lo mejor el
gobierno puede generar 300 millones de
acciones para cada uno de estos bancos
de manera que cada ciudadano
estadounidense hombre mujer y niño pueda
tener acceso a una de las acciones de
cada uno de estos bancos y yo creo que
esta sería una afirmación políticamente
muy poderosa y que también tiene sentido
económico
aquí los estadounidenses serían los
dueños del sistema bancario en lugar de
tener esta riqueza concentrada que ha
venido existiendo desde hace unos 50
años
mi amigo comenta que seguramente muchos
bancos se irían a la quiebra pero muchos
de ellos probablemente lo merecen de
manera que el sistema financiero se
preservaría si el nuevo banco quisiera
prestar nuevo dinero a nuevas personas
que lo necesitan lo podría hacer o se
podría hacer dinero comprando los viejos
préstamos con un descuento pero de todas
maneras se tendría una ganancia
económica obviamente mi compañero apunta
que esta solución no sería muy popular
en la política de los bancos y de los
banqueros actuales pero es una forma
mucho mejor de proteger el sistema
financiero y de minimizar el riesgo y
maximizar la recompensa del gobierno de
los eeuu
ya que les platiqué en resumen lo que
propone de solución mi amigo todo por ti
vamos a ver lo explicado aquí en
pantalla así que la solución de mi amigo
es tener 700 mil millones de dólares y
esto se va a repartir a nuevos bancos
que están siendo creados queremos que
sean varios para tener una sana
competencia vamos a decir que se van a
crear 70 nuevos bancos bancos diferentes
o quizás 50 bancos diferentes para que
estén en cada estado del país que sé que
suena loco es más vamos a trabajar con
50 bancos me gusta la idea un banco para
cada estado los cuales van a estar en
lugares alejados de los centros
financieros principales y van a comenzar
desde cero y estos bancos se van a
capitalizar con bueno dividamos 700 mil
millones entre 50 van a ser 14 cada uno
se capitaliza con con 14 mil millones de
dólares así que sus hojas de balance van
a lucir así esto
cada banco tenemos catorce mil millones
que es el equilibrio inicial van a tener
300 millones de acciones una acción para
cada ciudadano estadounidense y si esas
personas no quieren tener esas acciones
los pueden vender y estos serán bancos
miembros de la federación por lo que
estarán regulados pero tendrán una
décima parte del voto digamos que con
14.000 millones en bienes cada uno de
estos bancos puede controlar 140 mil
millones de bienes son 140 mil millones
que pueden prestar al mundo lo que
generaría buenas inversiones si es que
consideran que hay buenas ganancias si
creen que pueden invertir en negocios
privados lo pueden hacer quizás también
podrían hacer préstamos a otras
instituciones bancarias si es que
consideran que no es demasiado el riesgo
pueden correr algún riesgo saludable a
lo mejor a un 6% como les pide el
gobierno federal oa un 2% oa lo que sea
si es algo más riesgoso puede estar al
10 o al 12 por ciento
aquí un comentario aparte que quiero
hacer es que pareciera que la federación
está frustrada con
querer forzar que los bancos se presten
mutuamente a una tasa del 6% el 6% sigue
siendo bajo si yo tuviera que prestarle
dinero a alguien que puede ser la
quiebra la siguiente semana yo le
pediría al menos el 10 o el 12 o el 15
por ciento de interés y no creo que sea
una tasa de interés muy loca esto es lo
que pagaba las personas al inicio de la
década de 1980 y en ese entonces no
hablaban del armagedón financiero bueno
de cualquier manera cada uno de estos
bancos tendría 140 mil millones en
bienes y bueno no sé cuánto tendrían de
obligaciones
veamos 140 menos 14 serían 124 mil
millones en obligaciones y sería muy
fácil poder pedir prestado dinero
podrían recibir préstamos de diferentes
personas y por qué sería esto bueno
primero empiezan con una hoja de balance
prístina impecable nadie se preocupa por
qué tipo de cosas malas tienen en sus
bienes ya que todo esto es inversión
nueva y si el gobierno quiere asegurarse
de que estos bancos inicien con el pie
derecho pueden tener un respaldo
temporal del gobierno
rían ser patrocinados inicialmente y
temporalmente por el gobierno podremos
decir que tengan un respaldo del
gobierno por cinco años lo que quiere
decir es que si ustedes le prestan
dinero a estos bancos nuevos durante los
próximos cinco años y si por cualquier
extraña razón estos bancos tuvieran que
irse a la bancarrota el gobierno va a
respaldar a estos bancos por lo que
literalmente no habría riesgo alguno en
invertir en estos bancos y francamente
si se tuviera este respaldo de cinco
años por parte del gobierno yo creo que
muchas personas se sentirían motivadas
para contribuir al equilibrio en estos
bancos y el gobierno seguramente no
tendría que poner ni un centavo para
respaldar a los bancos de cualquier
manera aquí terminamos y continuaremos
en el siguiente vídeo